سيتم تشخيص واحدة من كل ثماني نساء في جميع أنحاء العالم بأنها
مصابة بسرطان الثدي طوال
حياتها ، ولكن عندما تصابين به مبكرًا ،
يكون لديك معدل نجاة 95 بالمائة
ونحن نساعد النساء من خلال إعطائهن
أداة يمكن أن يستخدمنها ربما للإصابة
بالسرطان في مراحل مبكرة.
لقد أصبح من الممكن تحقيق قصة كبيرة كبيرة من خلال تحليلات IBM cognos التي
تربط الأفكار
[الموسيقى] ،
اسمي جوليان ريوس وأنا الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركة إيوا عندما كنت في السادسة عشرة من عمري ،
أفا هي شركة تكنولوجية ونحن نعمل على
تطوير هذا التعداد
الصحي للثدي I  خلقتهم قبل ثلاث
سنوات ونصف ،
لقد نتج عن مشكلة شخصية للغاية
تم تشخيص أمي مرتين
بسرطان الثدي في البداية عندما كنت في الخامسة من
عمري
كانت تحصل على أفضل
علاج وأفضل فحص يمكن أن تحصل عليه
على الرغم من  أنها حصلت على تشخيص متأخر أن
السرطان مرض مخيف للغاية في تلك
اللحظة قررت أن أركز كل
جهودي وفهم سرطان الثدي
[موسيقى]
يتم إهمال النساء دون سن الأربعين تمامًا
من  تنضم إرشادات فحص سرطان الثدي
إلى النساء لا يمكنهن إجراء
تصوير الثدي بالأشعة السينية بسبب التعرض للإشعاع ،
لذلك تشعر يا رفاق بهذه
الفجوة الخاصة من خلال كونه جهازًا
يمكن استخدامه في المنزل ولا ينبعث منه أي
إشعاع ، هذا هو أحدث نموذج أولي من حيث
النسيج
لجهازنا يتم استخدام Eva كما  أي نوع من
الحمالات التي تضعينها عليك انتظري لمدة خمس
دقائق بداخلها لديك مستشعرات
تحدد درجة حرارة سطح الثدي
بعد ذلك تخلعه
وترسل البيانات إلى السحابة وإذا رأينا
بقعة ساخنة غير طبيعية أوراكل في
الثدي أو الكثير في التعلم
وخوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن أن
تفرق بين مريض سليم
وامرأة لديها احتمالية عالية
للإصابة بالسرطان 20٪ من النساء اللاتي نفحصهن
في عيادتنا يكون لهن نتيجة إيجابية
مما يعني أن هناك شذوذًا
في الصحافة
التي نستخدمها  التكنولوجيا لإنقاذ الأرواح من خلال
تمكين النساء لأول مرة في
التاريخ من امتلاك
صحة ثديهن في أيديهن ،
أمي خالية من السرطان ، صحيح لا  مع
أنها لا تزال تعاني من مشاكل صحية بسبب
العلاج العدواني الذي تلقته
عندما تم تشخيصها لأول مرة ، نريد
التأكد من عدم إصابة أي امرأة أخرى ولكن
بعض أحبائنا عانوا
وهذا هو وقود هذه الشركة
للتأكد من ذلك  لا يحدث مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]